[Musica]
allora io vorrei appunto raccontarvi una
storia allora siamo in estate in una
località in un villaggio una regione una
regione della cina
in questa regione della cina un uomo in
un bambino con in mano delle gabbiette
di legno si muovono cauti nella campagna
noi vediamo che loro salgono e scendono
dagli alberi con delle cassettine
afferrano qualcosa dei rami degli alberi
le inseriscono nelle cassettine le
chiudono risalgono su un altro albero e
rifanno la stessa procedura un gruppo di
turisti italiani non per caso un gruppo
turisti italiani sono incuriositi e la
guida turistica dice ma è una si tratta
di un insegnante e di un suo allievo che
stanno preparando portando delle cicale
e scuola per far conoscere i bambini e
le cicale tra i turisti c'è
un'insegnante e naturalmente insegnato e
sapeva già da quando ho sentito il
discorso della scuola sapeva già che
cosa avrebbero fatto cosa potremmo fare
un insegnante portandosi dietro una
cicala di scuola o al massimo a
studiarla dal punto di vista della
scienza può anche di sezionarla può
anche lavorare spiegando e direi non
solo spiegando ma comprendendo insomma
la forma della cicala
no dice la guida turistica che ha cinese
la porta una scuola per far sentire ai
bambini il canto delle cicale
come vedete è un altro punto di vista
noi possiamo insegnanti di solito
portano a scuola degli oggetti li
sezionano a livello astratto a livello
pratico ma difficilmente nell'occidente
portano un elemento e fanno sentire il
canto delle cicale
questa è una differenza ma cosa vuol
dire una differenza è una differenza
perché noi siamo storie di differenza
però attenzione non solo noi
io o tu che siamo differenza la
differenza sta nella relazione che io
stabilisco non sta nella cicala sta
nella relazione che stabilisco come
cicala questa è la differenza e quindi
proviamo a capire cosa significa nella
nostra vita essere differenza ma non in
quanto se ma in quanto relazione con
allora in quanto relazione con quello
che è importante
detto da un grandissimo antropologo
psicanalista psichiatra è che se noi
nella nostra esistenza
rompiamo questa struttura che connette
la relazione
rompiamo la struttura delle nostre
relazioni che abbiamo con le cose con
gli altri
noi corriamo il rischio di perdere il
valore e la qualità dell'alterità che
siano cose che siano relazioni e se
perdiamo valore perdiamo il senso non
perdiamo la cosa l'altro può essere un
nemico significa che io ho una relazione
con un nemico l'altro non è un nemico
quindi è nella relazione che io sento
che è un
questa è la differenza ed è importante
intuirla allora siamo differenza
assolutamente attraverso che cose io
riesco a cogliere questo siamo
differenza piuttosto nel sentire più che
nel comprendere sentire più che nel
comprende cosa significa significa e poi
torno e sentire che il comprendere
l'altro assume una posizione di funzione
quasi lo spiego io analizzo lo valuto lo
di sezione questo è il comprendere anche
se c'è questo cum prendere in realtà se
io lo comprendono categorizza il sentire
invece è diversa il comprendere
finiscono a strutture di comprendere
attenzione perché il comprendere e rara
ragione la razionalità quello che volete
voi non fa altro che strutturare e
questa struttura diventa a sua volta
strutturante e quindi a un continuo no
corsi dietro a strutturare le cose fino
a renderle minimalisti infilare nelle
quasi necessarie funzionali a un disegno
minimo della nostra intelligenza della
nostra conoscenza di sentire invece è
qualcosa d'altro perché nasce dentro
nasce nelle intersezioni che noi abbiamo
dentro di noi e in questo intersezioni
noi funzioniamo per relazione cioè la
relazione che ci riguarda è quella che
ci permette di stare al mondo perché noi
siamo relazione siamo differenza siamo
relazione esso e stiamo al mondo solo
per la relazione adesso vorrei fare con
voi se siete d'accordo
un piccolo esercizio ci state
allora provate a sentire il vostro
respiro
ascoltate il vostro respiro fatte
rientrare lo sguardo
guardatevi dentro
sentitelo sentite il flusso del respiro
dentro di voi
sentitelo lungo il corpo le mani i piedi
sentite che va oltre
sentitelo bene dentro sentite l'onda la
forma il rumore il suono i chiari scuri
le forme
cercate di andare al di là oltre oltre
oltre al respiro quello che sentiamo
sono forme flussi circolarità non
sentiamo finito determinato lineare il
respiro interno non ci porta alla
struttura ma ci porta la circolarità di
senso la circolarità di senso non è
ancora comprensibile e ancora un sentire
però ci porta e ci fa emergere altro ci
fa emergere altre verità questa
circolarità ci porta anche a qualcosa
che ancora più profondo dentro di noi
che non trattiamo quasi mai che è la
risonanza la risonanza è quello che ci
suona dentro quando noi facciamo
qualcosa o quando noi pensiamo quando
noi sogniamo quando noi immaginiamo
ecco il corso dentro che non è espresso
in qualcosa di particolare ricordatevi
che la prima risonanza nostra e il suono
perché nel ventre della madre
la prima cosa che noi cogliamo è il
suono il suono dei passi
se la madre del ritmo della madre il
suono dell'acqua dentro del liquido
amniotico questo sentiamo e questori
suono e questa risonanza quando il
bambino nasce rimane dentro non resta
fuori perché fuori usa altri canali
allora noi quando siamo in relazione nei
confronti di una cosa nei confronti
dell'altro noi dobbiamo sentire la
risonanza perché nella risonanza che
capiamo perché abbiamo quella relazione
che tipo di relazione abbiamo con
l'alterità qualsiasi alterità quella
relazione ci porta a capire se siamo in
grado di fare intersezioni se siamo in
grado di fare contaminazioni
se siamo in grado di costruire qualcosa
con l'alterità o se invece siamo fermi
nella nostra percezione razionale nella
nostra struttura nella nostra
addirittura nella nostra linearità di
dio di identità io sono io no io sono
relazione e per fare questa operazione
bisogna fare tutto un lavoro che è di
capire il senso di questi flussi di
queste forme che poi riconosco negli
atti concreti reali quando incontro un
uomo io sono una donna mi sento una
differenza quando incontro un migrante
io sono un nativo quando incontrò un
giovane perché io non sono un giovane
sono un anziano quando incontrò lio il
tool ecco io sento in questa relazione
un senso che mi dice tea che
comportamento possa avere che il
comportamento avuto che comportamento
potrò avere nel futuro
io devo spartire questo senso di me con
la differenza perché bateson diceva che
per entrare in relazione
noi dobbiamo perdere un po di sé non
entra in relazione con niente neanche
col camminare
neanche con il video con internet se tu
non perdi un po di te
e detto questo è chiaro che noi possiamo
capire questo soltanto se apriamo le
menti alla complessità la complessità
non è complicato non è infinito non è
nemmeno e plurale non è nemmeno in multi
la3 la complessità è un movimento
continuo con quelle forme che avevamo
dentro di noi che ci dice effettivamente
come ci possiamo muovere che tipo di
possibilità abbiamo e poi vedrete che
tipo di possibilità vi amo tenete
presente che l'accesso alla complessa
noi ci è stato dato
eppure la complessità è sempre esistita
ma non ci è stato dato
non ci è stato dato da una forma di
cultura che ci ha impedito questa
libertà di relazione perché quelle forme
di cultura ci hanno portato ad accettare
il dominio di qualcuno sui molti ci
hanno detto che la mente diversa dal
corpo e che è gerarchicamente superiore
al corpo
ci hanno detto che possiamo avere dei
nemici oggi ci dicono che i migranti
sono i nostri nemici che le donne sono
le nemiche degli uomini e gli uomini
sono i nemici del dow ci dicono tutte
queste cose che i vecchi sfruttano i
giovani ci dicono questo oggi è sempre
quella cultura deterministica quella che
ci struttura nel pensiero non quella che
apre a tutti e ci permette anche una
scelta e ci permette anche di costruire
le scelte perché io non non faccio
scelta se non la costruisco perché la
scelta la faccia della relazione non
faccio una scelta così io sono qui e
scelgo lui o cellule no lo stabilì la
relazione per fare la scelta
fate questo questo linguaggio
decidete scegliete organizzate fate sì
nella relazione quando conosco
quando sto quando mi sito quando mi apro
come come culturista quell'insegnante
che è capito che a scuola non si può
fare soltanto la dissezione della della
cicala quali se nell'analisi amo questa
cosa dal punto di vista anche della
sostenibilità insomma portare una cicala
la scuola nella gabbietta che poi grida
disperata perché nella gabbietta e non è
se beve non è questione di bomba
e questo semplicemente di punti di vista
e a me piacerebbe quell'insegnante lì e
io vorrei essere christian teli e spero
di diventarlo forse la mia età è un po
difficile ma insomma ma io credo di
esserlo io credo di esserlo e penso che
anche qualcuno di voi secondo me sa di
esserlo oppure si può situare su questa
relazione questa essenza di relazione
fino a diventare che cosa questa cultura
che ci ha usato ci ha abituato a
strutturarci a categorizzare sì un
teatro modo fino arrivare all'odio al
conflitto
l'odio è peggio del conflitto io ti odio
non so niente di te ma ti odio o son
sentito parlare che ci sei
sei arrivato via mare sei una donna che
sa che odio i figli gli anziani tutti i
professionisti
questa è la cultura la cultura dell'odio
è la cultura della strutturazione del
limite della limitatezza e del
radicalismo però tenete presente che
allora dobbiamo fare una cosa dobbiamo
rieducarci attraverso la relazione
dobbiamo rieducarci alla relazione alle
differenze e dobbiamo trovare un ata
grammatica di vita una tra grammatica
esperenziale un'altra grammatica di
conoscenza una grammatica concettuale
perché è importante questo ve lo spiego
perché è importante
gli insegnanti sanno ma anche genitori
sanno questo ma tutte le persone secondo
me sanno questo un buco di beckett
ri educare significa aprire le menti ma
non aprire la mente nel senso
dell'ottocento attraverso il sogno
l'immaginazione ristretta quei campi
limitati e quello a quella zona
local dove noi siamo cresciuti no che
sia stata l'agricoltura che sia stata
l'industria son sempre zone local nella
complessità la rieducazione e
l'immaginario che ci sta dietro che
immaginari è sempre esistito sempre
anche qui ci è stato impedito no o c'è
stato limitato c'è stato costretto c'è
stato direzionato questo immaginario
oggi ha più possibilità perché nella
complessità ci sono più possibilità
più incertezza e più confusione ma se io
sto nella relazione la capisco e conosco
e vedo le residenze l'opportunità che ci
sono dentro fuori dentro di me fuori di
me nell'altro nelle cose nelle
organizzazioni nelle istituzioni io
allora devo pensare che questa
immaginazione non deve essere un sogno
un'aspettativa una probabilità che ce
l'hanno pochi oggi le pro ma una
possibilità di vite diverse
una possibilità di vite diverse
i giovani lo sanno che se non trovano
qualcosa qui vanno da un'altra parte
se non ce la fanno con quel lavoro
possono diventare in un altro lavoro noi
dobbiamo puntare alla possibilità di
vite diverse
e questa possibilità ci viene data dall
immaginazione
perché oggi l'immaginazione concreta è
una pratica sociale è una pratica e ci
coinvolge in gruppo attraverso la
differenza in posso pensare altro non
posso pensare un'immaginazione aperta
dentro di me dentro al mio unico luogo
ristretto la posso pensare solo se esco
se incontro si stabiliscono relazioni e
se queste relazioni stabiliscano la
differenza e non l'identificazione con
l'altra
usciamo dalle identificazioni usciamo
dalle identificazioni lo dobbiamo a chi
lo dobbiamo lo dobbiamo alla nostra
natura di umani
naturacultura non è natura e nemmeno
quel tour natura cultura di umani anche
di non umani attenzione dobbiamo pensare
anche i non umani comprese le cose
lo dobbiamo ai nostri figli ai giovani
lo abbiamo i giovani lo dobbiamo a noi
lo dobbiamo alla nostra e altrui
diversità a tutte le diversità perché i
giovani noi le diversità costruiranno il
futuro grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]